[Music]
crazy rich Asians breaks the mold in
more ways than one
typically mid credit scenes appear only
in the big blockbusters of DC and Marvel
however crazy rich Asians delivers a
mysterious cameo at the film's clothes
that may have left some viewers
scratching their heads throughout this
video I'll be discussing the end of
crazy rich Asians and what this could
lead to in the film's sequel there will
be heavy spoilers here so what may be
worth skipping this video if you want to
go in with fresh eyes without the way
I'm definition and I ruin the movie so
you don't have to the film ends with the
star-crossed lovers celebrating their
engagement by throwing a massive party
during the scene Nick's cousin Astrid
makes eye contact with a man that
instantly sweeps her off her feet
fans of Glee will instantly recognize
the actor Harry Shum and are correct in
thinking that he will play a big part in
any sequels to come Shum has already
been cast as the part of Charlie Wu
from the novel's who was originally
engaged to asteroid when they were young
however due to their disapproving family
the couple were forced apart after a
huge argument and have not encountered
one another since Astrid and Charlie
reunite at the wedding and fall head
over heels once more Astrid lens of her
husband's affair which drives her to
move in with Charlie however things
become complicated when we learn that
Charlie already has a wife if this
doesn't sound crazy enough in the book
we discover that asteroids husband
hasn't actually been having an affair
and instead he's just been pretending to
have one in order to get out of his
marriage sure there are probably easier
ways to go about it but they wouldn't
make for much of an interesting story it
seems like producers of the film are
intentionally saving the tube's love
story for a sequel as they originally
shot a lot of scenes of them together
but then decided to cut them down due to
the film's
this is a shame as it would have been a
great inclusion but I guess we'll have
to wait till next time to find out how
it all turns out so what did you think
of crazy rotations do you think it lived
up to the book and what would you like
to see in the sequel comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and subscribe
to my channel I create content like this
weekly and they'll definitely be
something on here that you love if
you're a fan of films make sure you
check out my crazy fan theory on why
Nick Fury waited til infinity war to
call Captain Marvel which will be linked
up later this one and thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]